- I'm Kim Goff-Crews,
and it is my privilege to
welcome all of you today
to honor our veterans.
Before we begin, I would like to thank
our ROTC cadets and midshipmen
for presenting the colors
and to express our deep gratitude
to the Quinnipiac people for
the land on which we stand.
I also wanna acknowledge and
recognize our alumni leaders.
The Yale Alumni Association
is in the middle of a meeting
for the last couple of days.
They have changed their
schedule to join us
for this special event, so welcome.
But I also wanna make a special welcome,
and that's to the students,
the faculty, staff, and alumni
who are with us today,
who have served, who are serving,
and who are preparing to serve.
We are so grateful, all
of us are so grateful,
for the freedoms and privileges
that your sacrifices have made possible.
Now, during our ceremony,
you will hear from a veteran
leader and a current student,
and we will also honor a staff person
who has supported and
advocated for Yale veterans.
Our speakers and honorees
represent commitment
to honor and country, to our veterans,
and to those who care
for and support them.
Before we begin, it's
my pleasure to introduce
President Peter Salovey,
who's gonna share his thoughts
about our esteemed veterans.
President Salovey.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Kim, and
good morning everyone.
I'm really thrilled to
see so many students,
faculty members, staff,
and especially our alumni with us today
as we commemorate Veterans Day,
and I wish to begin
by extending a special warm welcome
to the veterans and Yale ROTC students
whom we are honored to have here with us.
You have our deepest gratitude and respect
for your contributions to our country,
for exemplifying a spirit of service
which dates to the
founding of our institution
and of the republic.
Indeed, the call to serve
society was inscribed
in this university's 1701 charter,
and this call has been answered dutifully
and with distinction by
generations of Yale students,
faculty, staff, and alumni
for over three centuries.
We think, for instance, of Nathan Hale,
perhaps the most famous Yale alumnus
to serve in the American Revolution,
who perished with the lone lament
that he had but one life
to lose for his country.
We think too of the nearly 30,000 Yalies
who served in the First
and Second World Wars,
Korea, and Vietnam,
and service members up to the present,
including those who you
see all around us today
who are carrying forward
a proud tradition.
We also reflect with reverence
on the service of those veterans
who were denied freedom
even as they fought
valiantly for its cause.
Patriots who,
as Dr. Cortlandt Van
Rensselaer Creed exclaimed,
"Still rallied to the sound
of liberty and union."
Dr. Creed, the first African American
to earn a medical degree at Yale,
served honorably in the Union
Army during the Civil War
in spite of tremendous
racism and discrimination.
Closer to our time,
patriots like Yale College
alumnus and my friend,
retired Lieutenant Colonel
Enoch Woodhouse, Woody,
one of the last surviving Tuskegee Airmen,
endured segregated conditions
in defense of this country.
I also think of Admiral Grace Hopper
who earned her PhD at Yale
and is the namesake of one
of our residential colleges.
She led in fields that were at
the time unwelcome to women.
And now in our era,
we are resolved to build as best we can
on their enduring legacies.
Yale's Reserve Officers
Training Corps program,
for instance, was recently lauded
by U.S. Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
for increasing diversity through
the officers it produces,
including in areas of
the active duty force
that are underrepresented by women.
Yale Law School meanwhile
is at the fore of the effort
to rid the veterans benefit
system of racial disparities.
And earlier this semester,
the U.S. News and World
Report recognized Yale
as the best college in
the nation for veterans
in part due to our commitment
to ensuring that a Yale education
is affordable to everyone.
I don't love those rankings,
but I do love it when we're number one.
(audience laughing)
Of course, our tradition
of service continues
through the students
who will one day join the eminent ranks
of the Yale veterans community.
The ROTC program on campus recently marked
the 10th anniversary of its return,
and the spirit of
sacrifice that links these
and future military members
is a hallmark of the
spirit of Yale itself.
It is the desire to ensure
the security and welfare
of this and future generations.
It is the desire to serve,
to look beyond self-interest.
It is in short the desire to
contribute to the common good.
I'm deeply grateful for the
veterans here with us today
who have given of themselves
to a better world,
and for the cadets and
midshipmen of our ROTC program
who have similarly felt and
answered the call to duty.
Your decision to serve in the armed forces
is especially critical
during this period of global turbulence.
Conflicts are escalating,
democracies are backsliding,
and right now the spirit of
division around the world
seems stronger than ever.
Yet today, we look around this room
and this community
and what we see is the spirit of service.
It's a spirit forged over centuries.
Indeed, the fabric of our nation
is woven by the individuals
who have defended it
for nearly 250 years.
The resilience and wisdom of our veterans
help to build a nation,
and their strength help
to bind it together
during difficult times.
Their courage helped save a
world torn apart by war twice.
Their determination has protected millions
from a life of oppression and hardship.
And as recent years have underscored,
their compassion and
commitment to humanity
have brought food, clothing,
and shelter, medication
to those in need of it most.
The exigent crises we face as
a country and global community
remind us anew of the fragility of peace,
but they also redouble our gratitude
for those who have answered
the call to protect it.
In both peace time and wartime,
Yalies have answered this call to duty,
and many have made the ultimate
sacrifice for their country.
Carved into the hallowed
walls of Memorial Hall
right outside those doors,
you can find the names of 1,020
Yale alumni killed in battle
since the American Revolution.
Out on Hewitt Quadrangle,
the memorial cenotaph honors
225 Yale students and alumni
who died in the Great War.
And the Ledyard flagstaff
is dedicated to the memory
of a young Yale alumnus
who died during the
Philippine-American war.
Today, we assemble in the
shadow of these campus landmarks
and in awe of the valor
to which they pay tribute
and of the veterans who gave
their loyalty to this nation.
I join a grateful university community
in saluting those who have
so nobly served this country
and advanced the cause of
peace around the world.
Thank you all very much.
(audience applauding)
("The Star-Spangled Banner")
- To a-ten-hut!
("The Star-Spangled Banner" continues)
(indistinct) rest!
- [Soldier] Order. Go!
- Grand architect of the
universe, called by many names,
in many languages, by many voices.
Today, we ask that your
guiding hands hold us
and all sisters and brothers
in military service near.
We are grateful to all who now
serve, all who have served,
and for those who,
in the words of President Abraham Lincoln,
"gave the last full measure of devotion
in service of their country."
We are joined in humility, gratitude,
and our own measure of devotion,
knowing that as we seek to understand
an increasingly complex world,
we are sheltered by the vigilant service
of citizens to our republic.
We ask special regards
for those who have served
but who have not yet been
found and returned home,
and for those who have returned
but who have yet to
find themselves at home.
We honor our military
and ask that whatever is required of them,
be informed by your infinite wisdom,
the light and truth,
as they honorably and loyally seek
to create a peaceful and
secure future for us all.
Amen.
- Good afternoon, President
Salovey, Secretary Goff-Crews,
Provost Strobel, Director
Bajwa, Rod Lowe, Dean Sodi,
the Veterans Day Committee,
distinguished guests,
family and friends,
members of our community,
and of course our veterans.
To everyone here today,
thank you for coming together
to celebrate those who,
during times of peace and war,
swore to defend our nation and
its most sacred principles.
It's a privilege to be with you all today
at an event hosted by a university
with such a long standing and
storied tradition of service.
Only a few moments' walk
away stands a statue
of one of this nation's
earliest and finest patriots,
placed adjacent to the
building he called home
while a student here at Yale.
Nathan Hale's famous last words,
that his only regret
is he had but one life
to lose for his country,
embodies the same principle
that is held by every person
who has worn our military's cloth.
If you speak to a hundred
different veterans,
you'll hear a hundred different stories,
but one principle is universally true:
each and every one of them
pledged to serve a cause
far greater than self at
great personal expense
and without any assurance
of what the future may hold.
I'm continually humbled and inspired
by those with whom I served
and by the veterans I've met
since hanging up my uniform,
and I want to thank everyone here today
who has worn, currently wears,
or one day will wear our nation's uniform.
My story with the
military, like many others,
does not begin with a family
tradition of martial service.
I never really thought
about joining the military
until my senior year of high school.
At the time, all I knew was
that I had to get away from home
and the military seemed like
a good opportunity to do so.
The determining factor
of why I chose to enlist in the
Marines was, in all honesty,
that I like their uniforms the best,
(audience laughing)
which I suppose is somewhat ironic
since I didn't know the
Marines had flight suits
and that's the uniform I
ended up wearing the most.
(audience laughing)
And so I shipped off to bootcamp
shortly after my high school graduation,
not sure of what would become of me.
I'll never forget that
first night in bootcamp.
I remember thinking repeatedly
that I had made the worst
decision of my life.
But as you quickly learn in the military,
you must adapt to new
situations and challenges
and excel in stressful environments,
whether it's making your bed
with a perfect 45 degree
fold in the corner
while a drill instructor
screams in your face,
or calling an Osprey to the
deck at night in heavy dust
while the enemy lurks in the darkness.
And so my initial apprehension gave way,
and as the Marine Corps
became my new home,
I realized that I had made
the greatest possible
decision by enlisting.
While I look back fondly on many moments
with some of the greatest
people I'll ever know,
my time in the military also created
some of my greatest struggles,
and leaving those in the past
at one point seemed insurmountable.
Returning home from deployment
was one of the hardest
things I've ever had to do.
Deployment itself was challenging enough.
It was hard to start each day with a brief
on the number of enemy killed in action
over the previous 24 hours
and the weapon systems we
were expected to encounter
throughout our flight,
to navigate through airbursts
and wonder if the next one
would be the one that took us down,
to see cities destroyed by airstrikes
and the ravages of war,
to point a machine gun
at another human being
and have to decide if he was the enemy
hiding within a civilian population
or an innocent bystander
caught in the middle of a war
he didn't ask for.
But it was also hard to return from that
to a place that no longer felt like home,
to go about each day
feeling like a part of me
was lost in the desert.
It was hard to leave behind a place
where I felt that
everything I did mattered,
not knowing if I'd ever have
that purpose in my life again.
It was harder still to
leave behind the military
along with the people
who were there with me
throughout it all.
For several years after
leaving the Marines,
I didn't want anything
to do with the military.
I avoided reaching out
to those I served with
and I did everything I
could to reclaim who I was
and leave the military
forever in the past.
But that's easier said than done.
My non-commissioned officer blood stripes
were beat into my legs,
and my sergeant chevrons
were pounded on my chest.
I fought for my wings
in the skies over Iraq,
and I earned the right to wear
the eagle, globe, and anchor.
These things are not given lightly,
and once given nothing can take them away.
I'm grateful that
they'll always be with me
and I no longer lament the part of me
that never returned from the desert
or avoid the memories
of my time in uniform
because those things
made me who I am today.
I'm forever grateful
for those who helped
me along this journey.
Professor Jeannie Johnson
for helping me find a path
when I left the Marines
and for being a friend and
mentor for nearly half a decade.
Rose McCard for helping me navigate
service after the military
and for growing my love of foreign policy
and international relations.
Jeannie was my professor
during my first semester of college.
While I certainly felt out of place
in our freshman introductory
international relations course
as a former Marine sergeant
with a disheveled beard
who had barely graduated high school,
Jeannie recognized that I understood
the importance of the
material we were learning
because I had lived through
international relations
at its most visceral level in Iraq.
She immediately took me under her wing
and has supported me
constantly ever since.
Rose was my supervisor
at the State Department.
As an army officer who
joined the State Department
after transitioning from active duty,
Rose quickly became an inspiration to me
as I sought to regain a
sense of purpose in life.
Because of my experience in the Marines
and Rose's belief in me,
I was able to work on a project
whose effects are right
now being used by Ukraine
to defend its independence,
to represent State Department equities
to the National Security Council,
and to help formulate policy
as crisises develop throughout the world.
Because of Jeannie and Rose,
I found my post-military purpose in life
in foreign relations.
But Jeannie and Rose's support for me
highlights something far more profound:
veterans bring something to the table
that is impossible to find anywhere else.
Veterans have real world experience
that is gained in the most
trying of circumstances,
skillsets that are
developed in furtherance
of the most serious tasks,
and an ability to succeed
in the most challenging environments.
I'm grateful for the incredible
faculty at Yale Law School
for recognizing this.
At the start of her term,
Dean Gerken immediately set
to work supporting veterans.
And thanks to her efforts,
Yale Law School isn't just
the best place to study law,
but is a place that veterans
can truly call home.
One of the greatest testaments
to Yale Law's commitment to veterans
is the Veterans Legal Services Clinic,
which under the leadership
of Mike Wishnie, Meghan
Brooks, and Jason Parkins
is a significant engine of
improvement to veterans' benefits
and has changed the lives
of countless veterans for the better.
It's telling that every semester
there's overwhelming student
interest to work in the clinic.
I also wouldn't be here today
without my family's support.
It can't be easy for any parent
to watch their child ship off to war,
and I can't imagine the
burdens my parents felt
knowing they signed my contract for me
when I was too young to enlist on my own.
Our military families deserve nothing
but our nation's highest
respect and gratitude.
They hold together families on their own
for months and years.
They say goodbye to
parents, siblings, children,
and significant others,
and live through periods
of incredible stress,
limited communication, and immense worry.
They often put their lives on hold
and move to places far
from familiar faces.
Nothing we could do could ever repay
the sacrifices you all have made.
And of course, I'm grateful
for those who are no longer with us,
whose sacrifices are the reason
we can be together today.
At many Marine Corps ceremonies,
there's an empty place set
at a table for the fallen.
While at first, this table to
me was just a solemn reminder
of the nature of military service,
as the years have passed,
more and more friends have
come to occupy that empty seat.
You live with me every day
and I'm forever thankful
for our memories together.
While I once ignored this day,
Veterans Day is now a
day that I take pride
in the best parts of my service
and try and heal from the difficult ones,
smile back on fond memories,
and express gratitude
for the challenges that
the military imposed,
cherish those who are still with us,
and honor those who are gone,
knowing that my time in the military
has given me the tools to
overcome the insurmountable,
and I'll always find inspiration
in my brothers and sisters
as they navigate their own paths.
To my fellow members of the Armed Forces,
however you choose to spend Veterans Day,
I'm grateful to be here
with you all today.
Thank you for answering the call.
Wherever you may be in your journey,
whether you're a member of our ROTC
who's training to take
charge of your first command,
you left the military decades ago,
or you fall somewhere in between,
I hope the future brings
you nothing but joy,
and know that your brothers and sisters
are rooting for your success.
Thank you for taking the time
today to honor our veterans.
May we honor them every day
by enjoying the blessings of
this nation that they served.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(somber music)
- [Soldier] To attention!
(somber music continues)
All right, rest!
- [Soldier] Order. Go!
- She's okay, she fainted.
She's okay, she's fine, (indistinct).
- Okay. All right.
- You should tell them.
- So just so you know
that our student is okay.
She's talking. She just fainted.
It is a little bit hot
in here, I have to say.
I don't think they were
expecting to be here that long,
but she's fine and we will
continue with our program, okay?
And actually, why don't we
give a round of applause
to our students, by the way?
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
And Michael, I wanna tell you,
your comments were really quite wonderful,
so we are really grateful that
you shared your story with us
and that you chose to come to Yale,
so welcome and thank you.
(audience applauding)
Now, one of the things
that was really poignant
about what Michael was talking about
was the need to have people in your sphere
who support you as a
veteran wherever you may be,
including at Yale.
And right now we want to, as a university,
recognize someone who has
made outstanding contributions
to veterans with the
Veterans Day Tribute Award.
This year, it is my great
honor to present the award
to Risa Sodi, the Assistant Dean
and Director of Academic
Advising and Special Programs
in Yale College.
Risa.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Now, many of us may know Risa
because she has been at the
university for 25 years,
but for the last nine years,
she has been the Director
of the Eli Whitney Program,
The Eli Whitney Student Program,
and the Transfer Student Programs,
and most of our Yale
College student veterans
find their way to Yale and to New Haven
through those two programs.
In 2013, there were six student veterans
in the Eli Whitney Program,
but today there are 36,
and Dean Sodi continues to provide
the same individualized and
loving attention and support
to each Eli Whitney student
with grace and generosity.
Her support has made countless students
feel as if they belong at Yale.
For example, former Eli Whitney student,
Yale College graduate,
and current Yale Law School
student Hillary Browning
recalls feeling really cared for
the moment she met Dean Sodi.
In Hillary's time at Yale College,
Dean Sodi provided not
only academic support,
but also personal guidance,
which she said really
helped her to succeed.
But in addition to her
supports of student,
student veterans, and the like,
she has also served on the
Veterans Day Ceremony Committee
for many, many years.
And so her dedication
and support to veterans,
to Yale's veterans in particular,
are recognized today for the service
that goes beyond the student community
to the entire veterans community.
So Risa, I am really pleased
to present to you today this award,
if you'd come and join me,
on behalf of the Veterans Day Committee,
in recognition of your support
for all of our veterans at Yale.
Please join me in welcoming her
and also sharing our admiration
and respect for her service.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Now, I just saw that Senator
Blumenthal has joined us
and I want to make sure
if you have time to make some comments,
that would be wonderful for us.
Welcome.
Another alum as well, so thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Thank you, congratulations, Dean Sodi,
and congratulations to Yale.
Very proud to be a graduate
of the law school here,
as are two of my children,
and another of my children
a graduate of the college.
And over the years,
I have seen Yale
become more and more
respectful, I think, is the right word,
of our veterans since
the days when I came here
as a law student shortly after
the Vietnam War.
And Yale has been at the forefront
of recognizing the immense contributions
made by our veterans
in a way that I think has provided a model
for other educational institutions
as I've seen them around the country.
I serve on the Veterans Affairs Committee
as well as on the Armed
Services Committee,
and I think the pattern
in our great nation,
the greatest in the history of the world,
is that all too often we fail.
We utterly fail
to address the needs of our veterans,
give them what they deserve,
when they most need it,
in the aftermath of their service.
And that is true of the
post-9/11 generation
of veterans as well.
Only literally this Congress
did we succeed in passing a measure,
it's called the PACT Act,
that will provide care and benefits
for veterans exposed to
toxic chemicals, poisons,
burn pits on the battlefield.
3.5 million veterans.
(audience applauding)
But it took years to do it.
I started working on it
a number of years ago.
It was bipartisan.
But the VA actually
opposed us in this effort,
just as it opposed us
when we sought to get care and benefits
for veterans who suffered
as a result of Agent Orange exposure
a generation before.
And it took literally a generation
to get that coverage.
And now the PACT Act will provide
the presumption of service connection
when people develop
23 different kinds of cancers
or liver disease, emphysema,
all of the hideous
diseases that result from
being in the way of these toxic chemicals.
If burn pits were located
anywhere around Yale
or around New Haven or
anywhere in Connecticut,
anywhere in the United States,
they would be a scandal,
there would be mass protests.
But our military men and women
were exposed to these toxic
chemicals day after day,
and I am sure some of
the veterans here today
know people who have
suffered from those diseases.
So I think one of the lessons is that
honoring our veterans
this day, fine to do.
I'm proud of our state
for having numerous ceremonies,
and I've been to several of them already.
Rhetoric, words, are good,
but even better and even more important,
and our obligation,
is to honor veterans in deed
and action, not just in word.
If you know a veteran who has
been in the military and deployed,
as two of my sons have,
during these 20 years of war,
make sure they get screened.
On just this last Tuesday,
every one of them is
eligible for screening.
Make sure they get screened
because cancers like glioblastoma
or more to the point kidney/liver diseases
can be caught early.
And we need to invest in
education, skill training,
healthcare for our veterans,
not only the physical wounds of war
that are apparent when people leave,
but also the invisible wounds of war
like these cancers that don't
manifest until years after,
or PTS
and other mental health issues.
Thank you for what you'll do
to make sure that our
veterans are taken care of.
We're very fortunate to
have here in West Haven
one of the best VA hospitals
in the whole country.
It needs more investment as well.
Again, action, not just word.
And thank you to Yale,
thank you to everyone who is here today,
for keeping faith with our
veterans and honoring them
as you're doing today.
Thank you very, very much.
(audience applauding)
- All right, are you ready
for a military salute?
All right, let's get going.
This is almost like the Harvard-Yale game,
but this is like, so we're
gonna really hear it now.
(patriotic music)
(audience applauding)
(patriotic music continues)
♪ Off we go ♪
♪ Into the wild blue yonder ♪
♪ Climbing high into the sun ♪
♪ Here they come ♪
♪ Zooming to meet our thunder ♪
♪ At 'em now, give 'em the gun ♪
♪ Give em the gun, hey ♪
♪ Down we dive ♪
♪ Spouting our flame from under ♪
♪ Off with one helluva roar ♪
♪ We live in fame ♪
♪ Or go down in flame, hey ♪
♪ Nothing'll stop the U.S. Air Force ♪
(patriotic music)
♪ From the halls of Montezuma ♪
♪ To the shores of Tripoli ♪
(audience applauding)
♪ We will fight our country's battles ♪
♪ In the air, on land, and sea ♪
♪ First to fight ♪
♪ For right and freedom ♪
♪ And to keep our honor clean ♪
♪ We are proud to claim the title ♪
♪ Of United States Marines ♪
(patriotic music)
♪ Stand, Navy, out to sea ♪
♪ Fight our battle cry ♪
♪ We'll never change our course ♪
♪ So vicious foe steer shy ♪
♪ Roll out the TNT ♪
♪ Oh, anchors aweigh ♪
♪ Sail on to victory ♪
♪ And sink their bones
to Davy Jones, hooray ♪
(patriotic music)
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(patriotic music continues)
(people indistinctly singing)
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Let us go forth
from this place of profound
memory and deep meaning
with grateful hearts,
grateful for the service and
sacrifice of our veterans
and their families.
Let us never forget
all that they have done
to bravely protect
freedom and human rights.
From the moment our veterans
made the commitment to serve,
they were committing to a life
that would be forever changed.
May we be ever mindful
that the life of a veteran
is always multidimensional
and is rooted in the pride
and promise of liberation,
coupled with the ever present possibility
of peril or alienation.
All of these things are held in tension
and contain a longing for
a certain kind of peace
to revive our weary world.
As we honor our veterans
and we seek to grow closer
to this abiding peace,
may we come to know
a peace born from wisdom
and understanding,
a peace nurtured with
compassion and mercy,
a peace strengthened by
courage and commitment.
And may we all be blessed
this day and every day
by the shimmering light
of our God of many names,
our God who creates, sustains,
and embraces all life.
Amen.
(audience applauding)
- So that is our ceremony,
and I wanna thank you all for coming.
Many thanks to the Planning Committee
and particularly our team
in Student Life Office,
the Secretary's Office,
who I know the military's prepared
to make changes on a dime,
but they have done pretty well,
so I wanna thank you very much
for changing everything quickly.
(audience applauding)
To our participants in our program,
thank all of you for being
on the stage with us.
And I also wanna give a special shout-out
to the Yale School of Music
Brass Ensemble, brilliant.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
You're awesome.
So as we close,
I want us to remember
that when today has passed
and when we return to our busy lives,
and they are busy nowadays,
I want us to remember
to continue to remember
the men and women of Yale
who have faithfully
and honestly served all of us.
They protected us, they've served us.
We are a stronger and
more diverse community
because of them.
So thank you all for your service,
and have a really, really good day.
(audience applauding)
(bright music)